I've got to talk to you about stranger
things oh so good so good now Joseph
Quinn's Eddie Munson became quite the
fan favorite this year is different this
year it's my year
I can feel it you're always these wild
fan theories out there but one of them
is that he could come back as vechna's
second in commandment what do you think
about that fan Theory I know you've got
so many that have floated around to you
and clearly you can't tell me too much
because we don't want too many spoilers
but what do you make of that I mean it's
a good it's a good fat Theory yeah yeah
yeah it's good what would you make of it
as an actor like is it I can't imagine
you've got folks that I'm sure you love
working opposite of and then they gotta
die at the end of the season yeah it
sucks sometimes but I feel like I I was
actually shocked that they they I I
loved Billy I love daycare Montgomery
who was killed off in season three I had
like a really good relationship with him
so for me it was like really hard to let
go of that um and the same thing with
Papa and this season so I have a really
good relationship with Matthew and to
let him go was was really hard is there
one person or character in particular
you hope they bring back for the final
season Papa
yeah yeah
I like that right we'll move on yeah I
know it can get a little uncomfortable
because you can't say too much but maybe
you can well I really don't know I mean
people say like oh you can't say too
much like don't spoil it I'm like oh no
I wish I could spoil it because you
don't know anything seriously you could
go to my phone right now you'd never
text me they never tell me anything
because they know that I talk to people
like you and I know that I'm gonna I'm
gonna spill the Deeds
as much as you can be a detective you
can also be the instigator yes yes it's
all good it's all good so that's so
interesting there's always a method to
the madness yeah what about the method
to Taylor Swift's Matt is we're all a
bunch of swifties out here that's true
what do you make of midnights Have you
listened to it how many times have you
listened to it literally on the in the
car right here I mean it's really Play
Ride oh yeah she's amazing isn't she uh
brilliant she is brilliant and what's
your favorite from the the new album
Bejeweled Bejeweled best believe I'm
still Bejeweled when I walk in the room
I can still make the whole place
draw the cat eyes sharp enough to kill a
man
two of my top favorites so good what
gets here connects into those two the
most
what's up but I just think it's like
also I felt like
the song was my theme for last night you
know like Bejeweled felt like there's
the jewels all over I really felt like
yeah you did and you looked Bejeweled
thank you
[Applause]
do you have fun at the premiere last
night it was it was really fun uh you
guys had it shut down like you were the
Beatles or something or you were Harry
Styles girl that's how we do it I mean
truly truly so round two of vanilla
homes we've got anola and Sherlock
teaming up on a Case together Dare I ask
what was it like for you working
opposite Henry Cavill again it was
really nice I mean just to be able to be
with him and and and work alongside him
he's really talented and to be able to
be around him again he's such a seasoned
actor he's so wise you know and like for
me to be able to watch that and work
with that every day has been a dream
come true I mean I feel like I could
play back what you said and what he said
and it's quite similar he is he has a
great admiration for you and respect for
you and especially what you've
accomplished at such a young age I mean
your producing mind is just as brilliant
as your on-air Talent thanks and
presence so hoping to do more of that in
the future yes yes absolutely I mean
my own production company pcma
Productions that produced this film and
and to be able to to create
opportunities instead of wait for them I
think is is you know a luck that I've
lucked out on really and to do it so
early too and to make it a family affair
yes which is awesome so good so what's
something surprising you can reveal to
us about Mr Cavill you told me last
night he's a bit secretive because I
said hey did you know about Superman
before the rest of us oh yeah but what
else Henry is
incredibly intelligent like book smart
like really really intelligent yeah it
is it's like you know it's like he knows
like he's just one of the people that
likes him knows latch it like it's just
like bizarre he reads so many books
really fast
um he knows so many stories he knows the
background behind words and things that
he's just really really intelligent wow
you know we love a good nerd it's okay
yeah uh Enola herself is becoming quite
the investigator so Millie how do you
think you would fare as a detective in
real life would you have what it takes
oh 100 I'm really good at getting and
getting into people I know every every
detail of everyone everybody that comes
up she was like really can you can you
help me out finding this out I'd be like
easy oh you get the good dates oh yeah
you get this the T to be spilled yes
it's so good so good so tell me this
clearly there's going to be a third in
Ola homes there has to be I have to say
the fans will without a doubt want it so
you know uh Harry was saying that this
one takes on a grittier a bit of a more
dangerous theme and tones to it so where
do you think anola can be launched to
and what are some of the tones and
things that you hope Incorporated in a
third go round see this one this one
it's so funny you're like don't spoil
anything for stranger things like this I
know I know what I know the theme for it
oh do you know because you got your
producer
yeah so um yeah so that one I do know of
um and uh but you can give us a tease I
definitely think she uh indulges a bit
more in her personal life this time
around oh yeah because I mean her new
boo thing yeah which is oddly enough art
is imitating life yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you